[Musique]
une rivière entièrement à sec des
communes privées d'eau potable jusqu'à
envisager de limiter les nouvelles
constructions
l'eau est elle en train de devenir un
produit de luxe pour en débattre
dimanche en politique installe ce matin
ses caméras au milieu du doubs a séché
sur la commune de maison du bois
lièvremont bonjour à tous alors même si
elle n'est pas due uniquement à la
sécheresse cette image interpelle
forcément sur une dizaine de kilomètres
le doubs a disparu de son lit aspiré par
les profondeurs dans ce secteur entre
pontarlier et morteau plusieurs communes
n'ont même plus du tout accès à l'eau
potable alors doit-on s'habituer à
manquer d'eau on va en débattre avec nos
quatre invités ici installé au milieu
d'eux du lit de la rivière doubs a séché
bonjour jean claude maire bon vous êtes
le maire de la commune voisine
d'auterive la fresse une commune
ravitaillés depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant par des camions-citerne il
n'y a plus d'eau potable dans votre
réseau également sur ce plateau éphémère
colette jacquey maire 9 maison du bois
lièvremont le village où nous nous
trouvons vous nous direz notamment vos
inquiétudes vos aussi par rapport à ses
ressources en eau et à
l'approvisionnement en eau potable
patrick genre conseiller régional divers
droite maire et président du grand
pontarlier bonjour la nouvelle du haut
doubs qui elle a des ressources propres
notamment avec les pluies de l'est puis
de la plaine d'arles et on fera le point
sur l'état des ressources avec vous et
puis jean-pierre l'étoile directeur de
la dréal bourgogne franche comté la
dréal c'est la direction régionale de
l'environnement de l'aménagement et du
logement
vous représentez ici les services de
l'état qui bien évidemment suivre la
situation avec attention bonjour à tous
les quatre mais toujours d'être ici sur
ce plateau éphémère donc alors comme
d'habitude vous pouvez participer à
cette émission devant votre écran de
télévision en interpellant directement
nos invités en leur posant vos questions
sur la page internet de l'émission sur
le site de france 3 bourgogne franche
comté sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
modeste qui s'affiche dean paul fc comme
dimanche en politique franche comté
et puis comme nous sommes en direct
également sur le réseau facebook où vous
pouvez nous suivre on salue d'ailleurs
les internautes qui nous regardent alors
colette jacquier on est ici sur votre
commune ma première question est très
simple
avez vous déjà connu une situation
pareille non non dans la durée
absolument pas là ça fait quand même un
certain temps et puis on sait que pour
les joue enfin les mois à venir la
situation sera pas mieux pour en tout
cas pour le mois d'octobre et novembre
les efforts sont à faire oui pour tout à
chacun en consommation d'eau et puis
après coup il est vrai que on a été
obligé il ya une semaine en arrière de
remettre de l'eau donc allé prendre de
l'eau sur deux syndicats des autres
dommartin donc c'est vrai qu'on demande
vraiment la population complète de faire
très attention à la consommation d'eau
potable
jean claude maire vous êtes vous le
maire par intérim de la commune voisine
d'auterive la presse une commune qui
fait partie de ces communes dans le haut
doubs qui n'a plus d'eau potable depuis
plusieurs semaines maintenant vous êtes
ravitailler en camion citerne
expliquez-nous comment ça se passe bon
nous n'avons plus d'eau depuis le 30
juillet donc je voudrais déjà remercier
monsieur le maire de pontarlier qui nous
fournit l'eau remerciait notre
transporteur d'eau monsieur jaked avec
dupont donc aujourd'hui la situation est
très grave
nous en sommes à 66 camion 25 mètres que
par camion qui nous fait un total de
1650 mètres cubes à 2 100 hétéro le
transport donc aujourd'hui nous sommes à
peu près à 20000 euros depuis le traduit
sans doute ça coûte vingt mille euros à
une petite commune ya combien
d'habitants au dôme à 230 à béton donc
on imagine que vous n'avez pas forcément
le budget pour cette dépense
supplémentaire en plus et non le budget
je sais pas mal tous et j'espère que
notre adn
j'appelle les élus à nous a aidés parce
que aujourd'hui on pourra plus faire
face à ce problème
je précise que au tri de laffrey ce
n'est évidemment pas la seule commune
dans ce cas à ne plus avoir du tout
d'eau potable dans les réseaux
non il ya les alliés aussi donc nous
celles et ceux que vous avez dupont qui
nous fournit l'eau donc avec des pompons
monte au réservoir de la fraise de
réservoir de la fraise nous avons deux
autres réservoirs lacombe doubt vive et
le château est depuis le château veut
distribuer les alliés jean-pierre
l'étoile est-ce que cette situation va
se généraliser ce que c'est une crainte
des services de l'état en gros faut-il
craindre crainte que l'eau potable
manque dans les semaines qui viennent à
d'autres communes
la réponse est malheureusement oui
puisque aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
perspective de nouvelles puis d'ici le
10 octobre
on sait que la situation est à la fois
exceptionnel mais risque de se
reproduire dans le temps elle est
exceptionnelle on est effectivement dans
un relief karstique l'eau s'infiltre
mais également il ya eu des grosses
crues qui ont fait qu'on a des colmater
la riviera décolmater les fissures et
donc s'infiltre encore davantage
et puis on est dans une sécheresse qui
est supérieur à 2003 il suffit de
regarder aujourd'hui des chants et des
vaches qui n'ont plus rien à manger par
exemple mais également le lit du doubs
donc il ya un vrai risque est ce que
disait madame le maire tout à l'heure et
juste il va falloir accroître les
solidarités encollées que entre les
collectivités pour approvisionner en
nous est ce qu'il ya un risque très
concrets de désamorçage notamment par
exemple au niveau du lac saint point
tout proche où dupuis de matech alimente
tout le pays de montbéliard à une partie
du territoire de belfort
hélas si ça décroche ce serait une
catastrophe enfin c'est plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'habitants qui
aura plus d'eau potable
tout à fait mais je pense qu'on y est
vigilant j'espère que l'on va tomber
parce que le désamorçage aujourd'hui le
niez pas mais s'il ya plus d'eau comme
on a eu l'hiver en 2016 et 2017 le
risque n'est pas nul
alors patrick du genre vous avez tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé depuis longtemps déjà
j'ai retrouvé une de vos interviews l'an
dernier à la même époque où vous disiez
attention attention pour tarlier a une
épée de damoclès au-dessus de la tête
finalement on est dans une situation qui
se répète
oui puisque disent toutes les personnes
qui ont parlé avant moi c'est que c'est
un épisode qui est exceptionnel qui est
par sa durée par ses conséquences par
son impact
mais surtout c'est un épisode qui
risquent de se renouveler et donc nous
avons une responsabilité collective
bien sûr les collectivités locales
l'état bien entendu mais également
l'ensemble des consommateurs parce que
cette situation parle pour le grand
pontarlier on à la nappe phréatique et
donc de la plaine de l'allier moi je
peux vous annoncer que d'ici une dizaine
de jours nous allons désamorcer le puits
numéro 3 ça veut dire que nous allons
devoir compenser sur le puits numéro 2
mais qui ne pourra absolument pas rendre
ce que produisait le puits numéro 3 et
donc nous allons devoir tirer beaucoup
plus d'eau à peu près aujourd'hui c'est
5 à 600 mètres cubes qui viennent du lac
nous allons passer à 2000 2500 mètres
cubes qui vont venir du lac tous les
jours ça veut dire que le lac va
continuer sa rebaisser la décote qui est
exceptionnel et historique et c'est
quand même la principale ressource en
eau puisque les nappes phréatiques ne se
renouvelle pas ne se rechargent pas et
donc là on a vraiment un défi pour
l'avenir et je pense que ça doit nous
interpeller ça doit nous interroger
nous-mêmes bien entendu les locaux pour
réfléchir différemment notre
développement à venir
alors vous le disiez situation
particulière cet été c'est le cas
évidemment depuis mi juin
la franche comté est confrontée à une
météo très particulière a besoin selon
météo france est plongée dans dans les
archives il ya des archis qui remonte à
la fin du 19e siècle à besançon et météo
france a constaté qu'on était sur le
deuxième été le plus chaud de toute
cette période là et le deuxième été le
plus sec
alors on est dans une situation
exceptionnelle mais qui se répète quand
même ces dernières années l'an dernier
encore vous tiriez la sonnette d'alarmé
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
s'habitue elle a manqué d'eau en tout
cas il faut s'habituer à la console wii
différemment il faut s'habituer à la
protéger différemment il faut s'habituer
à la halle à produire différemment
et puis on a vu un la succession d'un
été quand la cscec l'année dernière d'un
hiver exceptionnellement pluvieux avec
des idées ici même c'était ça recouvre
est pratiquement la passerelle il ya
quelques mois et aujourd'hui on est
complètement à sec donc on a des à-coups
climatiques qui vont d'eux qu'ils vont
se renouveler
donc on doit réfléchir différemment au
niveau local comme au niveau national
parce que l'eau va devenir un bien rare
un bien précieux pour lequel il faut
bien entendu que nous développions des
éléments de sécurisation et de
protection
alors je voulais dire dans cette
émission je vais me faire le relais de
questions qui nous sont posées sur
internet il ya des jeunes qui vous
interpellent et qui vous dit on laisse
des drainages abusif
les pompages dans les nappes on se fout
des écosystèmes aquatiques je reprends
ses besoins et des politiques arrosent
encore laisser croire que la gestion de
l'eau
intéresse en fait je me dis qu'il ya une
vaste hypocrisie des pouvoirs publics
est ce que les uns les autres vous
considérer qu'aujourd'hui vraiment tout
le monde a pris la mesure de la
situation
monsieur l'étoile globalement oui je
pense qu'il ya eu beaucoup de progrès
qui ont été faits depuis une dizaine
d'années notamment avec les
réglementations successives la directive
cadre sur l'eau au niveau européen on
préserve aujourd'hui les zones humides
on essaie de remettre les écosystèmes
notamment dans les rivières pour
permettre de réalimenter les nappes et
puis on essaie de lutter contre
l'artificialisation dans les communes
pour ré infiltrer de l'eau directement
pour qu'ils aillent directement dans les
nappes et qu'elle n'avait plus
directement à la mer voilà donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un long travail qui
demande beaucoup de financement beaucoup
de solidarité et de co construction
entre les élus les associations les
acteurs économiques et d'état sur les
restrictions d'eau il ya quelques jours
la fin de fin de cette semaine le grand
besançon est passé à son tour en niveau
crise qui est le plus haut niveau par
rapport aux restrictions d'eau quasiment
toute la franche comté est désormais
concerné le territoire de belfort y ait
en entier le jura et en entier est-ce
que vous pouvez nous rappeler en quoi ça
consiste ces restrictions des usages de
l'eau
oui donc d'abord même si aujourd'hui ils
sont moins concernés les agriculteurs
qui ne peuvent plus irrigué après des
industriels où il ya la mise en oeuvre
de restrictions d'eau dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui où ça n'impacte pas
l'activité économique mais et puis il ya
tous les usages diverses et variées qui
soit dans les communes pour l'arrosage
que ce soit dans les stations de lavage
que ce soit dans les scieries où on
autorise uniquement l'arrosage quand il
ya recyclage d'eau et pas quand il ya
pompage directement dans la nappe ou
dans la rivière college à qui vous avez
l'impression que tout le monde a pris la
mesure les élus les habitants aussi oui
moi je pense que au niveau 2 des élus de
la commune et des habitants on a fait
l'information énormément donc là il ya
une sensibilisation
mais on a toujours celui qui est à dire
ben moi je consomme l'eau qui ne se rend
pas compte et c'est ça qui nous fait mal
quoi par contre au niveau de nos ya du
gaspillage c'est ça ton plaisir ya
quelques paris et de gaspillage pour
certains mais globalement la population
fait des efforts et je la remercie
essais il faut continuer il faut
continuer d'information et et dire à
tout à chacun attention ne consommait
pas trop d'eau ne serait-ce qu'une
chasse d'eau un réservoir on met une
pierre de dans une bouteille d'eau on
consomme deux fois moins
je veux dire il ya des petites actions
très très simple des ruisseaux font les
grandes rivières les efforts de tout un
chacun font que on s'aide nous entre
nous quoi jean absolument jean-claude mr
tout le monde fait des efforts sur votre
commune par exemple tout le monde fait
des efforts mais il reste certains
citoyens que ça ne dérange pas de
gaspiller d'eau c'est malheureux et ça
me rend sa mairie je ne supporte pas ça
et en plus nous permet de nous dit nous
disputons c'est nicolas tôt ça consiste
en quoi le gaspillage vous avez des
exemples en tête
oui j'en ai 3 4 certaines personnes qui
laissent couler de l'eau dans les
pâturages sont une gêne pas y parla
mètres cubes de nuit sont les jeunes
parents alors que le camion 25 mètres
cubes de sa nature à la commune plus un
neuro 29
c'est tout le monde qui paye alors faut
que cette personne ces personnes
réagissent toutefois sa tension patrick
genre est-ce que c'est pas facile entre
guillemets de culpabiliser tout le monde
quand on est élu parce qu'il ya aussi
cette question là qui ce programme est
qu'on va jouer avec mon dossier à john
pour le dire que bien entendu des élus
sont sont conscients de cette difficulté
est certainement une prise de conscience
je me mets dedans sur la problématique
de l'eau qui est qui était à
relativement récente mais en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est que aujourd'hui on
doit préparer l'avenir et donc dans les
différents schémas d'organisation
territoriaux comme le schéma de
cohérence et littoral dans les plans
locaux d'urbanisme qui sont en train de
céder se développe et intercommunaux la
notion de ressources en eau de
protection de l'eau
la notion de de lutte contre l'un
permanisation peut-être que nous avons
peut-être je le dis
collectivement commis certaines erreurs
par le passé et je suis prêt à l'avouer
en tout cas par rapport à de jeunes je
peux vous l'assurer
et je peux vous assurer qu'on est tous
aujourd'hui embarqué dans cette liste
dans cette lutte et on ne culpabilise
pas tout le monde
on informe et sensibilise tout le monde
et il faut vraiment que ce soit une
action globale commune qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient menées mais nous avons
aussi une responsabilité dans l'urgence
dans l'est dans le très court terme
séparant les collectivités qui doivent
travailler pour améliorer le taux de
rendement de leur réseau de distribution
lutter contre toutes les pertes qu'il
peut y avoir sur les réseaux communaux
ou intercommunaux
ça c'est des actions très concrètes à
très court terme il ya quelques jours
christophe film que vous connaissez très
certainement qui est président du
syndicat des eaux et de l'assainissement
à besançon a écrit une lettre à
christine boutin la présidente du
département du doubs je vous cite une
partie de cette lettre n'attendons pas
une nouvelle sécheresse qui pourrait
être catastrophique pour mobiliser tous
nos moyens d'action
christophe lime donc adjoint communiste
à besançon qui prône une politique de
coopération et de solidarité et qui
souligne le caractère d'urgence
est-ce que effectivement l'ensemble des
élus ne jouent pas le jeu parce que en
creux c'est ce qui sous-entend du nom
mais je pense que j'en suis persuadé
tout le monde joue le jeu
alors après c'est vrai que selon l'état
de comme le ici avec le lit du doubs qui
est complètement à sec
on est peut-être plus réceptif à
l'urgence que dans certains endroits où
il ya encore pas par exemple le degré
d'urgence afin la gestion de crise pour
pour le tout ce qui est des ressources
en eau mais en tout cas la lettre gelé
huberdeau les jeux m'associer à cette
nécessité mais l'état le fait aussi
enfin nous le faisons à notre niveau
avec la création très prochaine d'un
syndicat mixte hautelook haut doubs
haute loue avec un epages donc on est un
établissement public de gestion des eaux
qui va gérer la notion de roue sur nous
sur un bassin versant donc une vraie
prise en compte en plus on est dans une
année avec le bassin rhin rhône on est
en tête de réseau donc tout ce qui se
passe ici peut réussir deux rangées en a
marre barreau navale monsieur l'étoile
mais moi je voulais simplement ajouté
que le parlement a quand même dit dans
la loi notre que les collectivités
devaient s'organiser notamment pour la
gestion de l'eau potable et de
l'assainissement
ce qui est très contesté par les maires
oui mais qu'aujourd'hui on the void à
perdre cette compétence aux équipes
vole pas que ça soit gérée et mutualisés
à un niveau supérieur
voilà mes mais aujourd'hui les
ressources sont différentes selon d'une
commune à l'autre et si on veut gérer
collectivement les ressources on sera
forcément obligé d'avoir une approche
collective
tout l'enjeu il est là à la fois pour la
gestion des réseaux pour trouver des
financements et pour distribuer l'eau de
manière équitable sur l'ensemble d'un
territoire
mais il faut forcer certains maires à
être solidaires parce que finalement
c'est ça interconnecter les réseaux
je pense que les événements vont nous
pousser tous ensemble à construire une
nouvelle politique de l'eau vous avez
parlé les uns les autres d'agriculture
tout à l'heure je vous propose d'écouter
un agriculteur thierry chalmin il est
président de la chambre d'agriculture de
haute saône et il parlait à catherine
aymeric problème de l'alimentation en
eau du bétail c'était vendredi je vous
propose d'écouter cet extrait on réagit
tous ensemble juste après
[Musique]
alors colette jacquet on est évidemment
une région d'élevage on est une région
agricole mais est il concevable de
donner de l'eau potable traiter à des
vaches le souci il est là en fin de
compte dans nos pâture par exemple pour
la commune on à 1300 unités gros bétail
donc le souci c'est que ces bêtes se
trouvent dans des communaux dans des
pâtures sans os puisqu'il ya plus de il
l'a bien dit et je crois que là bon on a
des réserves d'eau qui pourraient être
économisés on sait que la nuit nous ils
chargent leur tonalité leurs tonnes
pardon leur citerne pour arriver à
alimenter leurs bêtes
on peut quand même pas laisser périr les
bêtes bien sûr il faut vraiment que
voilà ça se passe comme ça pour
l'instant mais il va falloir étudier et
puis progresser dans cette optique là de
façon pas consommer l'eau potable qui
est coûteuse pour tout à chacun qui a
été traitée aux uv et voilà il ya
peut-être un autre processus à prendre
monsieur l'étoile oui je crois qu'il
faut imaginer de nouvelles ressources en
eau quand l'eau tombe c'est à dire
comment comment la récolter comme on l'a
conservée souvient qu'il ya eu beaucoup
d'eau ici au mois de janvier on a on a
eu affaire on n'aurait pas pu faire
l'émission ici le niveau peuvent être
bien 3 4 mètres au dessus alors c'est
vrai que voilà dans certaines régions on
a appris à faire des réserves
collinaires ce n'est pas le cas parce
que ici en franche-comté l'eau ne
manquaient pas mais peut-être que pour
le monde agricole il faudra trouver
d'autres dispositifs pour stocker l'eau
patrick genre ça vous choque vous qu'on
donne de l'eau potable du bétail ça me
choque que je suis conscient des
difficultés pour les agriculteurs dont
comme l'a dit qu'on y est on peut pas
laisser mourir les têtes de bétail
je vais simplement dire que là aussi ça
doit peut-être nous a menés avec les cv
de l'état à réfléchir différemment par
rapport à la notion de protège habilités
des puits ou des sources
on a sur le territoire du grand
pontarlier une source qui n'est pas
entre guillemets protégeable donc on
peut pas utiliser pour l'alimentation en
eau potable des habitants mais qu'on
pourrait très bien utilisé par exemple
pour alimenter les têtes de bétail en
vérifiant qu'elle ne sait pas puisque
c'est tout le plateau des fours qui
ressort dans cette dans cette source les
sources martin il ya aussi la gestion du
lac saint point qui est un vrai défi
pour l'avenir
on a aujourd'hui une réserve en eau qui
n'a pas inépuisables importante mais par
contre on croit qu'il ya 20 ans il ya
vingt pour cent de sa capacité à jamais
au site de mémoire de riverains en tout
cas vous nous avez annoncé tout à
l'heure que vous aller pomper davantage
le secteur du haussaire tous les
secteurs de métabief tout ça n'a plus
aucune source et donc tout le secteur du
haut est alimentée uniquement par le
donc les prises d'eau sur le lac la
ville de pontarlier d'ici quinze jours
de va certainement devoir doubler sa
même triplé entre guillemets c'est son
pompage sur le lac donc on va accentuer
la paix tu es un vrai défi donc
peut-être travailler sur les pinots
protégeable pour certaines alimentations
en eau et puis travaille également sur
le barrage du lac saint point qui est un
vrai défi pour l'avenir
il faut qu'on arrive à trouver une
solution avec les services de l'état
avec les collectivités locales
le futur syndicat mixte pour pouvoir le
rénover et qui jouent vraiment son rôle
est-ce qu'il faut aussi chercher de
nouvelles sources est-ce qu'il faut
prospecter monsieur parce que ça
dans les années 50 3 il y avait de l'eau
tout à chacun bon mais c'est vrai qu'ils
ont on a fait des réseaux on a fait les
captages du protection de captages
récemment donc là c'est très bien mais
avec un sous sol karstique comme on en a
un on a des difficultés
au vu de badauds la sécheresse et du
réchauffement climatique
et je crois qu'il va falloir de voir
partir dans des nappes chercher un peu
plus bas les ressources en eau ça c'est
pour l'avenir oui ça c'est pour l'avenir
si on revient à la situation présente
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour garantir
une ressource en eau potable à la
majorité des francs comtois de enfin je
veux dire demain à quoi parce que on a
tous compris qu'il y avait un caractère
d'urgence
est ce qu'il faut par exemple réduire le
débit d'eau on est missionnaire
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs à vous
revenez sur les agriculteurs à lézinnes
jeudi il ya beaucoup de nouveaux
bâtiments que les citernes
je pense que c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas
fait le plein au moment où l'eau tombée
à 6 et les agriculteurs ont fait
beaucoup d'efforts il ya eu par deux
fois je m'étais des subventions et
l'état on peut le remercier
par rapport à ça ils ont ils ont fait
des travaux ils ont fait pour avoir des
aménagements réservant d'eau mais
aujourd'hui on a tellement peu d'eau on
est sur une période trop trop critiquer
non plus tôt il a raison et donc sur
est-ce qu'il faut réduire le débit mois
pour moi oui
en tout cas il faut réduire la pression
due à la pression la voile de couper
l'eau c'est compliqué parce que derrière
ça fait des coupes bellicaud dormello en
pression enfin sa pop rock et des gros
dégâts sur des canalisations
c'est très compliqué à gérer parce que
sur lui-même qu'un des naseaux vous
pouvez très bien avoir un hôpital et
puis des résidences on peut pas gérer la
même manière l'eau pour l'hôpital par
exemple ou pour une résidence
individuelle en revanche réduit le débit
pourquoi pas réduire la pression pardon
pourquoi pas qui prend ce type de
décision ce sont les collectivités
locales c'est l'état donc là c'est une
mais cette édition qui pour moi en tout
cas ne doit pas être prise par une seule
copie
elle doit être partagée parce que on
peut enfin il faut vraiment se dévouent
d'un syndicat ou d'une zone géographique
il faut que chacun et chacun chacune des
collectivités à applique la même donc
les élus locaux sont devant leurs
responsabilités et fatalement je vous
propose d'écouter une élue locale
qu'après une décision assez radicale on
en a
les tout à l'heure c'est la maire de la
commune voisine des alliés qui manquent
donc comme chez vous à hauterive la
fresse je vous propose d'écouter sophie
bigre et sa commune est ravitaillée par
camion-citerne depuis plusieurs semaines
écoutez ce qu'elle a décidé de faire
madame monsieur madame dirait elle est
courageuse où elle est insensé mais je
crois qu'elles partagent aujourd'hui
alors je dis que tout le monde a que ce
soit au niveau jeu lé vite à l'heure des
plans locaux d'urbanisme intercommunaux
ou du schéma de cohérence territoriale
l'eau va être au centre des
préoccupations
il faut s'attendre à des mesures de
restriction sur le développement urbain
oui mais c'est très courageux je veux
dire le fait de dire vous vous limitez
les constructions sur le grand
pontarlier passé souhaite à communal qui
va être présenté à la collectivité 2010
et 2020 il y aura des mesures qui vont
qui va qui vont limiter en tout cas la
notion d'alimentation en eau sera
primordiale pour permettre le
développement il faut pas non plus que
parce qu'on est en tête de réseau d'eau
que d'eau d'eaux pluviales fado de
rivière faut pas non plus qu'on limite
le développement mais il faut que le
développement soit raisonnée colette
jacquet vous en pensez quoi vous moi je
pense qu'il faut que tout à chacun fasse
des efforts le développement on est sur
une région de la france où les
développements est très important on est
face à l'ondé à la frontière suisse sur
la lésion
donc je vais dire quelque part où on est
très gâté donc moi je pense que c'est
plus un effort de tout à chacun tout en
privilégiant quand même peut-être des
déconstructions à des endroits et pas
d'autres endroits voilà faire peut-être
un effort quoi suivant les zones
comment rendre compatible développement
démographique le développement
économique avec la raréfaction des
ressources monsieur l'étoile parce que
là on est vraiment là dedans car tout à
fait et je crois que c'est le rôle en
particulier des schémas de cohérence
territoriale qui aborde le développement
économique et urbain sur l'ensemble d'un
territoire et l'état veille quand il
donne ses enjeux à mettre l'enjeu en eau
potable comme un des premiers enjeux à
respecter dans le développement
voilà après il revient aux collectivités
et aux élus de savoir comment ils
aménagent leur territoire c'est une
compétence décentralisé mais en tout cas
l'état et sera très vigilant sur
cette question de la compatibilité entre
développement économique et raréfaction
des ressources on à caroline qui vous
pose une question qui nous dit dans le
jura lui aussi en sécheresse comme
l'année dernière le projet center pack
grands gaspilleurs d'eau est toujours en
cours est-ce que la ressource en eau
doit aussi être prise en compte je vais
m'adresser à vous parce que vous êtes
conseiller régional c'est la région qui
porte ce projet on sait qu effectivement
les projets de ce type sont très
consommateurs d'eau est ce que là il n'y
a pas une incompatibilité ou une
hypocrisie je sais pas alors que le
dossier propre du center parcs pas
m'engager puisque je ne connais pas
finalement ce dossier d'un peu de
technique
simplement ce que je faisais c'était
beaucoup d pad débattue au conseil
régional ont débattu mais robert fagg
pour l'instant bon la décision n'est pas
définitive
enfin il ya encore des études et autres
donc la salle lorsque je veux dire c'est
que il faut aussi que nous
réfléchissions par rapport à ce que des
ces messieurs les toiles pour les scot
schéma de cohérence territoriale avec
peut-être aussi imaginer différemment la
ressource en eau dire qu'on peut
peut-être comme vous lui disiez imaginer
des retenues collinaires on peut
peut-être imaginer des retenues d'eau
par des barrages qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui il ya des secteurs où on
pourrait créer artificiellement des
retenues d'eau qui pourrait répondre
aussi aux besoins développement urbain
des collectivités un développement
raisonné mais qui est indispensable
nécessaire tant pour les collectivités
simplement il faut qu'on aille recherché
aujourd'hui on a dépensé plus d'un
million d'euros sur le grand pontarlier
on ne sait pas toujours où retrouver
l'eau à la place des deux puits qui
doivent être fermées donc une vraie
difficulté également que lié à la
géologie du secteur mais je pense qu'il
faut qu'on essaie d'imaginer peut-être
que des solutions qui n'existe encore
aujourd'hui il est bientôt midi je vais
juste vous demander si vous êtes
confiant en l'avenir jean claude maire
il faut rester confiant oui vous pensez
que ça peut s'améliorer
vous êtes optimiste je pense pour finir
je voulais retrouver des ressources en
eau mais je pense qu'ils sont engagés
beaucoup d'argent et vous que la jac et
oui pour la communauté de communes donc
de mauvais noir on est sur la recherche
en eau
au niveau des gorges surville dupont
donc on a bon espoir de rush et enfin de
trouver une nappe et puis de pouvoir
fonctionner avec cette nappe donc mais
c'est vrai que c'est coûteux ça va
engager une norme aimant d'argent on a
déjà les études de démarrer mais c'est
vrai que c'est très et je pense que
c'est dans ce domaine là qu'il faut que
tout un chacun fasse un effort de
recherche en haut mais cette fois-ci par
des nappes et non plus par des sources
puisque les sources sont défectueuses
avec notre sol karstique
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre d'être
venu pour cette émission dans un cadre
assez exceptionnel même si ça interpelle
forcément dans un instant vous aurez
votre flash d'information régionale et
ensuite dimanche en politique continue
avec jean luc mélenchon qui est reçu par
francis letellier
bon dimanche à tous et merci à la syrie
ruffenach qui nous a accueillis ce matin